very good afternoon to you professor
John hustler Prize Committee member now
the laureates of the Prize in Economic
Sciences have just been announced as
Thomas J Sargent and Christopher a Sims
for their research on cause and effect
in the macroeconomy can you just provide
us with the main lines of motivation
from the committee as to why the prize
has been awarded to these two originals
there is a great interest in
understanding what's happening in to the
economy well when economic policy
changes but if we want to observe from
data try to estimate from data this
effects is of course of key importance
to understand what cost works and this
is this is difficult when you observe
only data and the main complication is
that an important driver of human
behavior is expectations about the
future right and we can't really observe
expectations what expectations did
people have what went on in their minds
when they when they made their decisions
right and when when the when the
laureates made their seminal
contributions this was of course well
understood but it was not really
understood how we could incorporate that
in macroeconomic models so what they
have done is to develop methods that
make it possible to distinguish cause
and effect
in macroeconomic data and then we can
answer questions like what happens to
unemployment what happens to GDP if when
interest rate is changed or if you
change the inflation toria's so what
would you say the main practical
benefits and applications are of their
findings so if you measure that in terms
of who actually uses the methods the in
daily basis I would say that it's
central banks
yeah but certainly also other agencies
at ministries and agencies responsible
for making business cycle forecasts and
things like that and not to forget
researchers say that basically all
modern empirical macroeconomic research
builds on the methods that that the
laureates have laid the foundation for
so these two laureates they have
developed tools for interpreting
historical macroeconomic data would you
say that the findings or their work
actually enables us to predict or
control the future I certainly think
that it has been very helpful for
central bank's in improving their
policies and making making monetary
policy better and and it's I mean they
have their methods have implied that
central banks know more or less what
happens when they change the interest
rate what happens to unemployment output
and inflation and without such a
knowledge the monetary policy cannot be
executed in in a good way so certainly
it has been very helpful for them but
also
and also for fiscal policy what what
happens if you you know propose a new if
you introduce a new stimulus package or
things like that the effects of those
measures can be analyzed with the
methods the laureates have developed but
one should realize that what they have
devised is is is a method of
constructing the models the tools that
we can use to answer these questions
they have not provided the complete
finished model that never is going to be
improved or on the contrary there is an
enormous amount of improvement going on
in various directions and and certainly
the the recent financial crisis has
pointed to development and in in kind of
new directions of introducing financial
markets in the system trying to
understand what happens with monetary
and fiscal policy when interest rates is
at the lower bound at zero so you can't
do anything more and these these
features of the models were not much
developed in the calmer times of the 90s
for example or in the beginning of this
decade but they will be now and/or being
developed now yeah because the models
that been in practical use of quite some
time I would say that they have kind of
become the main tool for example central
banks during the last 10 to 15 years
and so it's Thomas J sergeant and
Christopher Simmons and they've been
they are they've been awarded the prize
now what distinguishes their work from
each other so it's the methods are
slightly different and they are
applicable put two slightly different
aspects of economic policy so Sims has
largely focused on on what happens to
the economy if unexpected short-lived
events occur so that would be to talk
about policy it would be like a change
in the interest rate the change in the
interest rate set by the central bank of
the Federal Reserve or a change in the
tax rate that occur unexpected today
that will be the focus of Sims while
sergeant has focused more on on more
permanent structural changes in the
economy including in economic policies
so so what happens if you delegate
monetary policy to an independent
central bank that is asked to target the
particular goal of inflation for example
or if you introduce stringent budget
rules or for example that says that you
can't like in Sweden we have a target of
the budget surplus of 2% per year what
happens if you change that to introduce
another rule like that so subtract
changes in those kind of structural or
systemic aspects of economic policy the
effects of those on the economy that's
the focus of Sargent
very well yes there is a continuous
discussion between them which is kind of
interesting that what's in in between
what can be done with the different
methods and how in what way do they
complement each other so so the
discussion between the Lord did their
work has been very complementary and not
the least the discussion between them
has been very fruitful I think and in
the current climate of financial
instability how important is their work
well without the the knowledge that
their methods have given to central
banks I think it would have been much
much worse situation and but it's also
as I earlier note that it's it's it's
important to note that their methods are
continuously improved upon and and we
don't really have a good answer to what
happened during the financial crisis nor
what we should do in order to to reduce
the risk of something like this
happening again but we are pretty sure
that the methods that they have
developed will help us in finding the
answer to questions like that
although answers to questions like this
or never you know never final we will
never know the answer not sure and
closer and learn but social science it's
like that but there is never actually
even Natural Sciences like that
there is never a final answer to almost
any question professor John has - thank
you very much for your time today thank
you